Ahora que sabemos que podemos tratar las unidades
como variables algebraicas,
vamos a encontrar las unidades de una fórmula,
en este caso la fórmula es,
"k" igual a "b" entre "s" al cuadrado.
Y también nos dicen que "b" está en centímetros
y que "s" está en gramos por centímetro.
¿Cuáles serán las unidades de "k"?
Los invito a que pausen el video y piensen en ello.
Vamos a imaginar algunos valores para "b"
y para "s" y veamos qué pasa.
Aquí yo digo que "b" va a ser igual a 1 cm y también digo que "s" va a ser igual a 1 gramo sobre cm.
Obviamente estos valores los elijo por conveniencia,
vamos a sustituir estos valores en la fórmula,
nos va a quedar que "k" es igual a "b" y yo
definí "b" como 1 cm entre "s" al cuadrado,
"s" es 1 g por cm, por lo que me va a quedar
1 g por cm, todo esto al cuadrado.
Ya habíamos hablado de que podemos manipular
las unidades como variables algebraicas.
Podemos escribir esto como, 1 cm entre 1 al
cuadrado es 1, g entre cm, todo esto al cuadrado.
Esto viene de la idea de que "a" por "b" al
cuadrado es lo mismo que tener "a" cuadrada
por "b" cuadrada y también está la idea de que si tenemos "a" entre "b", todo esto al cuadrado,
va a ser igual a tener "a" al
cuadrado entre "b" al cuadrado.
Por lo que esto va a ser igual, 1 cm entre
1 por gramos al cuadrado entre cm al cuadrado.
Y sabemos que esto es lo mismo que tener 1cm multiplicado por el recíproco del denominador,
por 1 cm cuadrados entre gramos al cuadrado.
Bueno, pues si recuerdo que estos los puedo
tratar como variables algebraicas,
cm por cm al cuadrado, esto va a ser igual a cm al
cubo entre gramos al cuadrado,
y bueno 1 por 1 va a ser 1.
Recordemos que aquí yo invente
los valores de "b" y de "s",
lo importante aquí son las unidades de la fórmula.
Cuando "b" está en centímetros y cuando
"s" está en gramos sobre centímetro,
pues la fórmula estará en términos de centímetros
cúbicos entre gramos al cuadrado.
¿Quién nos dice pues que esto del centímetro
cúbico lo puedo interpretar como volumen?
Va a estar dividido entre una masa al cuadrado,
gramos al cuadrado que no es tan intuitivo,
pero estas son las unidades
de "k" con estas características.